your privacy is about to get signed away
have you even been told Congress and
President Obama are on the verge of
passing a surveillance bill that many
are calling the Patriot Act 2.0 it takes
that eerie bulk data collection section
of the Patriot Act what the NSA has had
a field day with and sets it in stone
it's called sisse the cybersecurity
information sharing act the goal is to
stop cyberattacks like the ones on chase
Target or Sony which to be fair probably
made Sony more money off of the
interview than it would have otherwise
but hey it seems like a good idea
protect our info from being hacked but
the devil is in the details or anyone
who bothers to read the bill sisyphus
iLET eighths and expands surveillance it
would allow companies to openly share
your emails phone calls text messages
credit cards social security information
anything with Homeland Security and then
Homeland Security curates it and
immediately shares it to government
agencies like the Department of Defense
the FBI and of course the NSA it could
also share that info with other
companies if they think it poses any
kind of cybersecurity threat problem is
that under sisse your info could be
handed over for a whole host of other
suspicious reasons and that is open to
interpretation privacy and civil rights
groups say sisse is too vague when it
comes to what is considered a threat and
grants total access to your information
without taking enough measures to
protect it the bill also overrides any
other electronic protections Americans
have under the law but how is this
different than what the NSA has already
been doing with sisse government and
business will be working closer together
than ever to be in your personal
business but it's voluntary if companies
cooperate they not only get access to
the information sharing they would be
free of liability from let's say someone
who wants to sue over privacy by
like the lawsuit Wikipedia and others
have against the NSA right now it's no
wonder then why big telecom companies
like Verizon AT&T and Time Warner have
all come out in favor of versions of
this bill the thing is the Patriot Act
section 215 the bulk data collection
part is expiring on June 1st
so if sisse passes it could be its
replacement but lawmakers aren't ready
to kiss the Patriot Act goodbye some
want to rein it in a wee bit with the
u.s. Freedom Act while others want to
extend it to 2020 even though Human
Rights Watch called it a mass privacy
violation that has affected media
freedom the public's right to know and
the ability of Americans to hold the US
government to account and even though
the White House's own privacy and civil
liberties oversight board said section
215 has had minimal value in
safeguarding the nation from terrorism
and could not point to a single instance
when the program made a concrete
difference in the outcome of a terrorism
investigation so can we have cyber
security national security and privacy
and as these debates heat up in
Washington one has to ask who's asking
us
this entire spying program has been done
in secret and it was done intentionally
and and the electorate the people of the
country have been kept